Pennywise was famously first brought to
life by Tim Curry in the original it
miniseries if the filmmakers behind the
new it movies were going to make their
mark they needed a penny wise for the
ages here's how bill skarsgård rose to
the challenge
skarsgård began developing his take on
penny wise well before he actually
started shooting any scenes he took
plenty of inspiration from Stephen
King's original novel which helped him
understand the balance between penny
wise this evil cosmic origin and it's
more recognizable clown form but he had
very few visual cues to draw from as he
first began to flesh out what made the
creature tick this created certain
challenges in designing the character
particularly in terms of his voice which
in the film ranges from childlike to
nasally and wavering to outright
monstrous favorite for skarsgård that
voice in its many facets could not fully
come into his head until he saw what
penny wise actually looked like he told
Collider it was really when we did the
full makeup test and see what the
character would actually look like my
first test with the prosthetics and
makeup was where I saw what the
character would actually look like with
me in it and something I needed to
explore to discover what this thing
would sound like with makeup artists
digital effects artists costumers and
director Andy machetes own designs for
the characters skarsgård had a lot of
help getting into the look of penny wise
penny wise is demonic grin for example
is created by skarsgård drooping his
lower lip down so that it almost comes
to a point that's not a prosthetic or
digital effect but simply something he's
always been able to do can we see that
keys to my eye just for that camera yeah
there we go what moose Getty was
designing the character he had the idea
that sometimes one of Pennywise his eyes
would wander and told skarsgård that he
would add the lazy eye in digitally in
post-production skarsgård explained that
he could do it and reveal that he could
trigger his own lazy eye it's one of the
chances that the actor that you cast and
do that practically because Pennywise
takes the form of a clown his costume
was obviously always going to be a key
part of the overall look and for that
moose Getty turned to costume designer
Janie Bryant rather than take the more
modern circus clown approach of the
miniseries Bryant's went for something a
little more timeless with Victorian and
even Elizabethan influence to give it a
sense of history and even in
eyetality in shaping the costume Bryant
added peplum around the waist a rough at
the neck and other assorted blossoms of
fabric to create a certain effect Bryant
explained I wanted it to have an organic
gourd or pumpkin kind of effect it helps
exaggerate certain parts of the body the
costume is very nipped in the waist and
with the peplum and bloomers it has an
expansive silhouettes the exaggerated
effects created by the costume gives the
already tall skarsgård the look of
having impossibly long limbs and the
tightness around his torso suggests the
body of an insect scuttling around the
sewers of Derry Brian also emphasized
the high waist and kept the pants short
to add to the characters childlike
qualities in preparing for the role
skarsgård watched the 1990 miniseries
adaptation of its featuring Tim Curry's
generation terrifying performance as the
original penny wise he also made the
decision not to specifically study curry
because he knew his Pennywise needed to
be different to that end skarsgård
brought together an intriguing and
diverse array of influences he studied
footage of animals to help him get into
the more predatory aspects of the
character and found himself particularly
drawn to hyenas and bears as influences
he also drew inspiration from another
iconic clown of cinema Heath Ledger's
Joker in the dark nights those skarsgård
acknowledged there were limits to that
comparison since quotes Heath Ledger's
Joker is rooted in the real you can
breakdown the psychology he acknowledged
however that the same rules didn't apply
to penny wise since he's not quote a
real person
he sticks the blade in my mouth let's
put a smile on that face
both skarsgård and mu sketti have
emphasized the childlike quality of
penny wise and to help bring that into
the performance particularly when penny
wise lunges at his victims
skarsgård took inspiration from his
little brother he told Rolling Stone I
don't know if you've seen kids run like
this but they move their arms way too
fast and it looks really really funny
and I just love the way my brother ran
as a kid it was just out of synch so I
incorporated that into the character and
you get this really explosive effect
it's really unsettling when it happens
[Music]
though bosquet II was determined to use
practical effects as often as possible
in the film even allowing skarsgård to
do quite a few of his own stunts
Pennywise is still a shape-shifting
monster from another dimension which
meant that sometimes stunt doubles and
digital effects were going to be the way
to go digital effects came in handy when
it came to designing Pennywise his
expanding mouth with its rows of teeth
according to rodeo FX visual effects
supervisor Arnaud Brisebois the effects
team designed a digital rig that allowed
them to animate Pennywise his terrifying
mouth with as much detail as possible
Brisebois told sci-fi the teeth rig was
all hand animated we basically modeled
the teeth all individually or as
clusters that could be grown and
oriented in any way the digital effects
team was also called upon for the
sequence in which Pennywise crawls out
of the fridge in addition to of course
the final showdown in which the
character is constantly changing shape
Brisebois explains basically what they
did was bring in all the stunt
performers into a gym and they learned
the choreography and they motion
captured this we built really quick CG
assets for all the characters including
penny wise and we planned out all his
transformations and the action check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]